[Music]
[Music]
you
greetings for you [ __ ] out
there and periscope fill uncle Joey here
trying to [ __ ] make up for
yesterday's periscope debacle but who
gives a [ __ ] that's the past and today
is the future [ __ ] it's Thursday
the 18th of May
you're slinging dick and giving out
lunch boxes without a construction hat
on and you understand me uncle Joey's
here to make it all better you're
probably sitting there go one more dad
who gives a [ __ ]
you're going there you put in your hate
and then it's a [ __ ] Friday dick
slings day you understand me
both you're podcasting up put a week
Jake Ellenberger dean del Rey in my man
writing Bozzio you're set and ready to
[ __ ] go you understand me you're
looking that's holding you back if you
[ __ ]
and not having a bowl in you I'm ready
to go I had my [ __ ] primal milkshake
at my [ __ ] CBB and now we'll complete
in the morning [ __ ] process but the
bone of death
look at it like a [ __ ] soldier today
with smoking ghosts og from per any and
also the assassin understand me would
take a light to make beautiful but I'm
happy you're here and you get a weekend
ready you follow me
I got a nice meeting for breakfast I got
a meeting for lunch I got two spots
tonight one at the [ __ ] army barracks
and one at the [ __ ] commie stood up a
little later away from me I'll be they
understand me I'll be there and that's
it it on my day [ __ ] planned out a man
without a plan is not a [ __ ]
man when you knew that you know that you
know that why the [ __ ] dilly-dallying
around
strap the pair on Thursday cuts up this
part of those nut sacs and then get no
pool around nobody wants blisters on
their nuts axis a lot explaining to do
you understand me but besides that is
[ __ ] happening it's all just your
[ __ ] around you got barbecue schooler
millions in the air and you having a
good time but you know what right after
[ __ ] Labor Day it's over [ __ ]
were back to grind three months from
Christmas we start this party in Austin
the 15th of September and then I take
the [ __ ] party train to New York
[ __ ] City where it all started
with Jesus landed where the pilgrims had
a [ __ ] coke party right there on
Times Square a lot of people don't know
that I'm telling you right [ __ ] it now
and we take it the doctor will get the
tickets now those tickets go quick and
both know something place it's not Emily
you crying later Joey I need a single
ticket with the buck I thought you'd
button all this bounce up huh
anyway and feeling good my head's in the
right place my family's healthy your
family's healthy I can't ask for
anything [ __ ]
[Music]
get the [ __ ] Thursday started what
type of [ __ ] do would I be if I
didn't call on you and [ __ ] mash you
to smoke apartment when your friends to
coffee when you would get everybody
tomorrow
I was passing flow people don't do that
no more uncle Joey never [ __ ] forget
her buddies worried about texting and
bogeyman it the other [ __ ] snapchat [ __ ]
that [ __ ] who calls from [ __ ] no
more old school
your uncle [ __ ] Joey why cuz I love
you concept that's why let's try this
assassin
this is nice oh this smells like a
ninja's [ __ ] shoot like [ __ ] soy
sauce and foot [ __ ] fungus mixed
together a shoe comes up with this [ __ ]
thank God I smoked reefer you insane
look at that nice the smooth nobody's
dying nobody's missing an eyeball it's
just a slight family that's the most
important thing of a family dog
that's weak you don't like that's the
connection you don't have what other
podcast if you don't listen to the
church and you don't know what the [ __ ]
we're talking about with family we're
[ __ ] stronger than floppy shoe
leather you understand we're [ __ ]
tough within the [ __ ] Ming Dynasty
with tough tougher than that before you
make your prediction is jerk motion
always remember one thing you never seen
a bookie with a part-time job okay he's
no [ __ ] loser
look to see where the [ __ ] public
opinions going and bet against it that's
gambling [ __ ] tip number one from you
uncle Joey and trust me I've put on a
lot of bets I lost a lot of bets but
I've also come on [ __ ] shining
towards the last twenty years when
you're a kid you're a dumb [ __ ] you go
with the status quo you just give me the
[ __ ] money
bookies can't wait for you to turn 21
Ike it's like the [ __ ] tobacco
companies I have a guaranteed income off
21 year olds 226 until you lose
everything and then you're sucking dick
for the [ __ ] Knicks that doesn't have
to happen you just hang with y'all go
Joey you might learn something you dumb
[ __ ] instead of banging heads look at my
face for the clothes on my face with my
eyeballs you did that lasted this long
does that be [ __ ] Dylan around
drinking [ __ ] kelp and [ __ ] didn't
know because I've been playing and
Murphy [ __ ] war because I could help
you out don't believe the [ __ ] right
just look to see what public man and a
bet against it take a chance Columbus
did [ __ ] you think people would
have [ __ ] cheated me [ __ ] no but look
I'm the underdog again you never see a
bookie with a part-time [ __ ] job
blasted number [ __ ] 100 Joey's
[ __ ] the world which translates them
don't believe that I don't say you know
it's like to put a button and go to bed
you know what that's like I do
super [ __ ] you so just go to bed just
put them better and go night-night drop
a [ __ ] ving
look at that not a little assassin and
that's it your days of [ __ ] complete
you started your morning off with Uncle
Joe gets everybody takes vitamin K you
[ __ ] take vitamin [ __ ] pH see
what Uncle Joe is after you
[ __ ] take vitamin THC but uncle
Joey
why be a cheerleader if you're not gonna
get paid your pumps I'm saying always
remember I gotta be a cheerleader if
you're not gonna get paid
always remember that lesson number two
from uncle Joey's we're gonna shop with
your little shirt
don't [ __ ] Assasin's don't know nothin
they show up to pick up an envelope they
get their dick something they call home
nobody knows not understand
I'm gonna have beauty right there that's
nothing but [ __ ] heart and soul right
there coming at you when you breathe
that you [ __ ] change what the [ __ ]
was that that just hit me it's not like
bad breath and refunds but there was
something in that [ __ ] plants I don't
give a [ __ ] what my family starting off
at Thursday morning swinging dict and
giving our [ __ ] that's it
we're here with that I'm stone to the
goose the [ __ ] mission was completely
understand but the mission of this whole
thing before you go on a mission you got
anxious now what is the [ __ ] what is
the mission why am I doing this
you know why does I want to see the duck
who wants to walk around and see the
[ __ ] I want to see the darkness
understand me but darkness is what you
want to see cause what you see the
darkness the light is [ __ ] easy
always a moment
I know you bad [ __ ] gonna smoke
around I'm showing up by Jesus on a
Sunday morning and we're smoke around
them and [ __ ] you anyway I love you
[ __ ] have a good day
don't let nobody [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] dream you understand me
remember a dream and a mind [ __ ] two
different things you don't learn to sort
them out
alright a dream and a mind flop is two
different things that weren't the sort
of man I did took me a long time to
admit it [ __ ] prison cell I realized
what a dream of my [ __ ] was but with the
same happen to you grab your dick don't
let nobody tell you what to do today and
tell them all the Sun that [ __ ] bone
of debt and stay black uncle Joey loves
you don't forget about me the church is
ready for you tonight I'm out tomorrow
I'm out
remember New York a loss to miss have
done that's all you [ __ ] me to know
cuffs up and stay black